and i realized the only wrong thing to
say is to say nothing
meghan markle is taking a step back from
her friendship with jessica mulroney
one of my closest girlfriends is here
jessica mulrooney
it all started last week when jessica
found herself embroiled in controversy
after canadian influencer sasha exeter
called her out on social media
after sasha said jessica made
problematic moves
when exeter used her own platform to
support black lives matter
listen i'm by no means calling jess a
racist but what i will say
is this she is very well aware
of her wealth her perceived power
and privilege because of the color of
her skin
and that my friends gave her the
momentary confidence
to come from my livelihood in writing
textbook white privilege really in my
personal opinion
jessica has since apologized to sasha on
social media
but her actions came with a price ctv
dropped her show
i do redo and she's no longer a
contributor on good morning america
i know you know that black lives matter
now a source is opening up to e.t about
the fallout between megan and jessica
saying the duchess has distanced herself
because of jessica's
unacceptable and offensive comments the
source added that megan's friends have
been
concerned for some time that jessica has
been profiting from her relationship
with megan
and using it to further her brand but
when it comes to reports that meghan has
completely cut jessica
off our source says that's a bit of an
exaggeration
quote jessica made an error in judgment
which was regrettable and for which she
has apologized
and made a vow to step back and learn
from her insensitivity
according to the source it's also worth
noting that jessica was a source of
strength for megan
during some of her most difficult times
including when jessica watched megan's
newborn son
archie while she finished up business in
the uk before stepping down from the
royal family
so the first thing i want to say to you
is that i'm sorry
i am so sorry that you have to grow up
in a
world where this is still present for
now
megan is focused on doing work that's
important to her like developing her
foundation with husband prince harry
and learning from community leaders
about social justice and equality
the black lives matters movement matters
to megan
and it matters to harry and i understand
that this is going to be
an area where we're going to see the
couple doing a lot more work and taking
a lot more interest
they've been very busy with the covered
efforts and their focus is now i'm told
shifting
onto this movement that black lives
matters is something that really
resonates
with both of them